The gay dating app Grindr
released a bunch
of very naughty emoji this week.
They're pretty LGBT cute.
I know. They are.
They're pretty great.
Um, I'm not gay--
not that cool--
but people do tell me
that I am allowed on Twitter.
-(laughter)
-So...
-Cool or gay?
-HARDWICK: Gay.
-Okay.
-HARDWICK: Not... Yeah. Uh...
So let me just translate this
just a little bit.
Okay, this log with a sunrise is
-for when you have morning wood,
all right? -(applause)
This emoji of a peach
with a knife and fork
is for when you're talking
about for eating (bleep).
(laughter)
All right,
now these all look dirty,
but emoji can have
many interpretations.
So comedians, what is
a safe-for-work explanation
of one
of these new Grindr emoji?
Jessica, let's start with you.
Yeah. The guy in the leather,
um--
he is reminding you that
you have Village People
in your area.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
Lonely Village People
in your area
-ready to meet up. Points.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Sam.
Uh, the bearded guy here
is a reminder
that Zach Galifianakis has just
been attacked by a grizzly.
Okay, points.
Points.
-Brian.
-The eggplant
must be this long
to get into my casser-hole.
All right, points. Very good.